one of the failure modes of empathy is
our susceptibility to anecdotal data
just a good story will get us to not
think clearly but what about empathy in
the context of just discussing ideas
with other people and then there's a
large number of people like in this
country
you know red and blue half the
population believes certain things on
immigration or on the response to the
pandemic or any kind of controversial
issue even if if the election was fairly
executed
having an empathy for their world view
trying to understand where they're
coming from not just in the explicit
statement of their idea but the entirety
of like the roots from which their ideas
thumbs that kind of empathy while you're
discussing ideas what is in your Pursuit
Of Truth having empathy for the
perspective of a large number of other
people
versus Raw mathematical reason I think
it's important but I just it only takes
you so far right it doesn't it doesn't
get you to truth right it's not the
truth is not a
is not decided by you know Democratic
principles and
um certain people believe things for
understandable reasons but those reasons
are nonetheless bad reasons right they
don't scale they don't generalize
they're not reasons anyone should adopt
for themselves or or respect you know
epistemologically and yet their their
circumstance is understandable and it's
something you can care about right and
so yeah like let me just take I think
there's many examples of this that you
might be thinking of but
I mean one one that comes to mind is
I've been super critical of trump
obviously and
um I've been super critical of certain
people for endorsing him or not
criticizing him when he really made it
you know patently obvious who he was you
know if there had been any doubt
initially there was no doubt when we
have a sitting president who's not not
um agreeing to a peaceful transfer of
power
right so
um
I'm I'm critical of all of that and yet
the fact that
many millions of Americans didn't see
what was wrong with Trump or bought into
the
um didn't see through his con right I
mean they bought into the idea that he
was a brilliant businessman who who
might just be able to change things
because he's so unconventional and so
you know his heart is in the right place
you know he's really a man of the people
even though he's a you know gold-plated
everything in his life
um
they bought the myth somehow uh of you
know the largely because they had seen
him on television for
almost a decade and a half uh pretending
to be this genius businessman who could
get things done
um
it's understandable to me that many very
frustrated people who have not had their
hopes and dreams actualized
uh who have been
the victims of globalism and and
many other you know current trends uh
it's understandable that they would
be confused and and and not see the
liability of electing a grossly
incompetent
morbidly narcissistic person into the
into the the presidency
um so I don't so which is to say that I
don't blame there are many many millions
of people who I don't necessarily blame
for the Trump phenomenon but I can
nonetheless bemoan the phenomenon as as
indicative of you know very bad
uh State of Affairs in our society right
so it's it's there's two levels to it I
mean one is I think you have to call a
spade a spade when you're talking about
how things actually work and what things
are are likely to happen or not but then
you can recognize it people are have
very different life experiences and and
yeah I mean I think empathy and you know
probably the better word for what I
would hope to embody there is compassion
right like really you know you
who to really wish people well you know
and really wish you know strangers well
effortlessly wish them well I mean to
realize that you there is no opposition
between in the at bottom there's no real
opposition between selfishness and
selflessness because wise selfishness
really takes into account
other people's happiness I mean you what
you know which do you want to live in a
society where you have everything but
most other people have nothing
uh or do you want to live in a society
where you're surrounded by happy
creative self-actualized people who are
having their hopes and dreams realized I
think it's obvious that the second
Society is much better however much you
can guard your good luck
but what about having empathy for
certain principles that people believe
for example
the the pushback the other perspective
on this because you said bought the myth
of trump as a great businessman there
could be a lot of people that are
supporters of trump who could say
that Sam Harris bought the myth that we
have this government
of the People by the people that
actually represents the people as
opposed to a bunch of Elites who are
running a giant bureaucracy that is
corrupt that is feeding themselves and
they're actually not representing the
people and then here's this Chaos Agent
Trump who speaks off the top of his head
yeah he's flawed in all this number of
ways he's uh more comedian than he is a
presidential type of figure and he's
actually creating the kind of chaos
that's going to shake up this
bureaucracy shake up the elites that are
so uncomfortable because they don't want
the world to know about the game they
got running on everybody else so that's
yeah that's the kind of perspective that
they would take and say yeah there's
these flaws that Trump has but this is
necessary I agree with the first part of
this so I haven't bought the myth that
it's uh
you know a truly representative
democracy in in the way that we would
you might idealize
um
and
you know on some level means this is a
different conversation but some of them
I'm not even sure how much I think it
should be right like I'm not sure
um we want in the end
everyone's opinion give an equal weight
about you know just what we should do
about anything and I include myself in
that I mean there are many topics around
which
I don't deserve to have a strong opinion
because I don't know what I'm talking
about right or what I would be talking
about if I had a strong opinion so
um
and I think we'll probably get to that
to some of those topics because I've
declined to have certain conversations
on my podcast just because I think I'm
the wrong person to have that
conversation right because and and it's
um and I think it's important to see
those
bright lines in in one's life and in in
the moment politically
and ethically so yeah I think
um so leave aside the the viability of
democracy uh but I I'm I'm under no
illusions that all of our institutions
are you know worth preserving precisely
as they have been up into the moment
this great orange wrecking ball came
swinging through our lives but
I just It Was a Very Bad Bet to elect
someone who is grossly incompetent and
um or worse than incompetent
um genuinely malevolent in his
selfishness right I think and this is
something we know based on literally
Decades of him being in the public eye
right he's not as he's not a public
servant in any normal sense of that term
and he couldn't possibly give an honest
or sane answer to the question the
question you asked me about empathy and
reason and and like how should we you
know what should guide us
um
I I genuinely think he is missing some
necessary moral and and psychological
tools right and this this is I can feel
compassion for him as a human being
because I think having those things is
incredibly important and genuinely
loving other people is incredibly
important and and knowing what all
that's about is is that's really the
good stuff in life and I I um I think
he's missing a lot of that but I think
we we don't want to promote people to to
the highest positions of power in our
society who are far outliers in
in pathological terms right we want them
to be far outliers in in if in the best
case in wisdom and compassion and some
of the things you've
some of the topics you brought up I mean
we want someone to be deeply informed we
want someone to be
um uh
unusually curious unusually alert to how
they may be wrong or getting things
wrong consequentially he's none of those
things and if in so far as we're going
to get normal mediocrities in that role
which I think you know is often the best
we could expect let's get normal
mediocrities in that role not uh you
know once in a generation
narcissists and
um
uh frauds I mean it's like the let me
just take honesty as a single variable
right I think you want yeah yes it's
possible that
most politicians lie at least some of
the time I don't think that's a good
thing I think people should be gen you
know generally honest
um even to a fault
um yes there are certain circumstances
where lion I think is necessary it's
kind of on a Continuum of self-defense
and violence so it's like if you're
gonna you know if the Nazis come to your
door and ask you if you've got Anne
Frank in the attic I think it's okay to
lie to them
um
but uh
you know Trump there's I arguably
there's never been a person in that
anyone could name in in human history
who's lied with with that kind of
velocity
um I mean it's just it was it was a just
a blizzard of Lies Great and Small you
know to to pointless and and to and
effective but is just
it
it says something
uh fairly alarming about our society
that a person of that character got
promoted and so uh yes I have compassion
and concern for for half of the society
who didn't see it that way and that's
going to sound elitist and and uh
and smug or something for anyone who's
who's on that side listening to me but
um it's genuine I mean I understand that
like like I barely have the I'm like one
of the luckiest people in the world and
I barely have the bandwidth to pay
attention to half the things I should
pay attention to in order to have an
opinion about half the things we're
going to talk about right so how much
less bandwidth to somebody who's working
two jobs or you know a single mom who's
who's you know raising you know
multiple kids you know even a single kid
it's just it's unimaginable to me that
people have the bandwidth to to Really
track this stuff and so then they jump
on social media and they they see they
get inundated by misinformation and they
see what their favorite influencer just
said
um and now they're worried about
vaccines and they're it's just it's
we're living in an environment where our
in the information space has become so
corrupted and we've built machines to to
further corrupt it you know I mean we've
built a business model for the internet
that it further corrupts it uh so it's
it is just
um
it's chaos in informational terms and
I don't fault people for being confused
and impatient and uh at the at their
wit's end and
um yes Trump was a an enormous [__] you
to The Establishment and and that's that
was understandable for many reasons to
me Sam Harris the great Sam Harris is
somebody I've looked up to for a long
time
as a beacon of voice of reason and
there's this meme on the internet and I
would love you to steal man the case for
it and against that Trump broke Sam
Harris's brain
that there's something is
disproportionately to the actual impact
that Trump had on our society he had
an impact on the div on the ability of
balanced calm rational Minds to see the
world clearly to think clearly you being
one of the beacons of that is there is
there a degree to which he broke your
brain
uh well Otherwise Known As Trump
derangements medical competition yeah I
mean I think Trump derangement syndrome
is a very clever meme because it it just
uh throws the you know the problem back
on the person who's criticizing Trump
but in truth the true
Trump derangement syndrome was not to
have seen how dangerous and divisive it
would be to promote someone like Trump
to that position of power and to not and
in the in the final moment not to see
how uh
untenable it was
to still support someone who you know a
sitting president who was not committing
to a peaceful transfer of power I mean
that was if if that wasn't a bright line
for you you have been deranged by
something uh because that was you know
the that was one minute to midnight for
our democracy as far as I'm concerned
and I think it really was but for
the the Integrity of a few people that
we didn't suffer some real
constitutional crisis and and real
emergency you know after January 6. I
mean if Mike Pence had caved in and
decided to not certify the election
right uh if it literally you can count
on two hands the number of people who
held things together at that moment and
so it was so it wasn't for want of
trying on Trump's part that we we um
didn't succumb to some you know real
truly Uncharted uh uh catastrophe with
our democracy so the fact that that
didn't happen
is not a sign that those of us who were
worried that it was
so close to happening were exaggerating
the problem I mean it's like you know
you almost got run over by a car but you
didn't and so you know you're the fact
that you're adrenalized and you're
thinking you know but boy that was
dangerous I probably shouldn't you know
you know wander in the middle of the
street uh with my eyes closed
um you weren't wrong to feel that you
really had a problem right
um
and came very close to something truly
uh terrible so I think that's where we
were and I think we shouldn't do that
again right so the fact that he's he's
still he's coming back around as
potentially a viable candidate you know
I'm not spending much time thinking
about it frankly because it's you know
I'm I'm waiting for the moment where it
requires some thought
um I mean it did
it took up
uh I don't know how many podcasts I
devoted to the topic
it wasn't that I mean it wasn't that
many in the end you know against the the
number of podcasts I I devoted to other
topics but there are people who look at
Trump and just find him funny
entertaining not especially threatening
is like not a you know just it's just
good fun to see somebody who's like
who's just not taking anything seriously
and it's just just putting a you know a
stick in the wheel of of business as
usual again and again and again and
again
um
and they don't really see anything much
at stake right it doesn't really doesn't
really matter if we don't support NATO
it doesn't really matter if he says he
trusts Putin more than our intelligence
Services uh I mean none of this is it
doesn't matter if he's on the one hand
saying that he loves uh
the leader of North Korea and on the
other threatening is threatens to to you
know bomb them back to the Stone Age
right on Twitter
it's all it all can be taken in the
spirit of kind of reality television
it's like this is just this is the part
of the movie that's just fun to watch
right and
I understand that I can even inhabit
that space for a few minutes at a time
but
there's a deeper concern that we're in
the process of entertaining ourselves to
death right that we're just not taking
things seriously and this is it's a
problem I've had with several other
people we might name who just who just
appear to me to be goofing around at
scale and they lack a kind of moral
seriousness I mean they're touching big
problems where lives hang in the balance
but they're just [__] around and
I think they're really important
problems that we have to get our head
straight around
and we need you know it's not to say
that that institutions don't become
corrupt I think they do and I think and
I'm quite worried that you know both
about the the loss of trust in our
institutions and the
the fact that trust has eroded for good
reason right that they have become less
trustworthy I I think you know they've
become infected by
you know political ideologies that are
not truth tracking I mean I I worry
about all of that
um
but I just think the we need
institutions we need to rebuild them we
need
we need experts who are real experts we
need to Value expertise over
you know amateurish speculation and
conspiracy thinking and just you know
and [__] the kind of amateur
speculation we're doing on this very
podcast
I'm usually alert to the moments where
I'm
just guessing or where I actually feel
like I'm talking from within my
wheelhouse and I try to Telegraph that a
fair amount with people
um
so yeah I mean it but it's not
it's different like I mean you can
invite someone onto your podcast who's
an expert about something that you're
you you're not an expert
about and then you
you in the process of getting more
informed yourself your your audience is
getting more informed so you're asking
smart questions and you might be pushing
back at the margins but you know that
when push comes to shove on that topic
you really don't have a basis to have a
a strong opinion and
if you were going to form a a a a strong
opinion that was this counter to the
expert you have in front of you it's
going to be by deference to some other
expert who you've brought in or who
you've heard about or whose work you've
read or whatever but there's a paradox
to
how we value Authority in science that
most people don't understand and I think
we should at some point unravel that
because it's the basis
for a lot of public confusion and
frankly it's the basis for a lot of you
know criticism I've received on these
topics whereas you know people think
that I'm a
you know I I'm against Free Speech or
I'm an establishment shill or it's it's
like I just think I'm a credit
credentialist I just think people with
phds from ivy league universities should
you know run everything
it's not true but there's a ton of confu
there's a lot to cut through to get to
Daylight there because people are
um
very confused about how we value
Authority in the service of rationality
generally you've talked about it but
it's just interesting the intensity of
feeling you have you've you've had this
famous phrase about Hunter Biden and
children in the basement can you just
revisit this case so let me
let me give another perspective on the
situation of January 6th and Trump in
general
it's possible that January 6th and
things of that nature revealed to our
democracy is actually pretty fragile
and then Trump is not a malevolent an
ultra competent malevolent figure but
it's simply a jokester
and he just by creating the chaos
revealed that it's all pretty fragile
because you're a student in history and
there's a lot of people like Vladimir
Lenin Hitler who are exceptionally
competent at controlling power
at being Executives and taking that
power controlling the generals
controlling all the figures involved and
certainly not tweeting but working in
the shadows behind the scenes to gain
power and they did so extremely
confidently and that is how they were
able to gain power the the pushback with
Trump is doing none of that
he was creating which he's very good at
creating drama
sometimes for humor's sake sometimes for
drama's sake and simply revealed that
our democracy is fragile
and so he's not this uh once in a
generation horrible figure once in a
generation narcissist no I I don't think
he's he's a
a truly scary Sinister you know
putin-like or you know Hitler much less
hitler-like figure not at all I mean
he's not ideological he doesn't care
about anything beyond himself so it's
not
um
no no he's much less scary than any
really scary you know totalitarian right
I mean and he's he's more Brave New
World than 1984. this is what you know
Eric Weinstein never stops um
badgering me about but you know he's
still wrong Eric
um you know I I can you know my analogy
for Trump was that he's an evil Chauncey
Gardner I don't know if you remember the
the
um the the book or the film being there
uh with it with Peter Sellers
um but you know Peter Sellers is this
Gardener who really doesn't know
anything
um but he gets recognized as this wise
man and he gets promoted to immense
power in Washington because he's
speaking in these kind of in a semblance
of wisdom he's got these very simple
aphorisms or it would seem to be
aphorisms he's just talking all he cares
about is gardening he's just talking
about his garden all the time but you
know he'll say something but yeah you
know in the spring you know the new
shoots will will Bloom and people read
into that some kind of Genius you know
Insight politically and so he gets
promoted and so that's that's the joke
of the film for me Trump has always been
someone like an evil Chauncey Gardner
he's he's
not to say he's totally yes he has a
certain kind of Genius he's got a genius
for creating a spectacle around himself
right he's got a genius for getting the
the eye of the media always coming back
to him
um but it it's only it's a kind of
it's a kind of you know self-promotion
that only works if you actually are
truly Shameless and don't care about
having a reputation for anything that
that I or you would want to have a
reputation for right it's like it's pure
the pure pornography of attention right
and he just wants more of it
um I think the truly depressing and
genuinely scary thing was that
we have a country that at least half of
the country given how
uh
broken our society is in many ways we
have a country that didn't see anything
wrong with that bringing someone who's
uh who obviously doesn't know what he
should know to be president
and who's obviously not a good person
right obviously doesn't care about
people can't even pretend to care about
people really right in a credible way
um
and so I mean this if there's a silver
line into this it it's it's along the
lines you just sketched it shows us how
vulnerable our system is to a truly
brilliant and Sinister figure right I
mean like a I I think we are
um we really dodged a bullet yeah
someone far more competent
and conniving and ideological could have
exploited our system in a way that Trump
didn't and I and that's um yeah so if if
we
plug those holes eventually
um that would be a good thing and he
would have done a good thing for our
society right I mean one of the things
we realized
and I think nobody knew I mean I
certainly didn't know it and I didn't
hear anyone talk about it
is how much our system
relies on Norms rather than laws yeah
civility yeah it's just like it's it's
quite possible that he never did
anything illegal you know truly a truly
illegal I maybe I think he probably did
a few illegal things but like illegal
such that he really should be thrown in
jail for it you know
um at least that remains to be seen
so all of the chaos all of the you know
all of the
diminishment of our stature in the world
all of the Just the the opportunity
costs of spending years focused on
nonsense
um
all that was just Norm violations
all that was just that was just all a
matter of not saying the thing you
should say but that doesn't mean they're
insignificant right it's not that it's
like it's not illegal for a sitting
president to say
no I'm not going to commit to a peaceful
transfer of power right we'll wait and
see whether I win if I win
it was the election was was was valid if
I lose it was fraudulent right but
aren't those
humorous perturbations to our system of
Civility such that we know what the
limits are and now we start to think
that and have these kinds of discussions
but that wasn't a humorous perturbation
because he did everything he could
granted he wasn't very competent but he
did everything he could to try to steal
the election I mean the irony is he
claimed to have an election stolen from
him all the while doing everything he
could to steal it declaring it
fraudulent in advance trying to get the
votes to to not be counted as the
evening wore on knowing that they were
going to be disproportionately Democrat
Democrat votes
um because of the the you know because
of the position he took on mail-in
ballots I mean all of it was fairly
calculated
the whole circus of of of you know the
clown car that crashed into you know
Four Seasons Landscaping right and and
he got Rudy Giuliani with his hair dying
you got Sydney Powell and all these
gross incompetent people lying as freely
as they could breathe about election
fraud right and all these things are
getting thrown out by you know
Republican largely Republican election
officials and Republican judges
um it wasn't it wasn't for want of
trying that he didn't maintain his power
in this country he really tried to steal
the presidency he just was not competent
and the people around him weren't
competent so that's a good thing and
it's worth not letting that happen again
but he wasn't competent so he didn't do
everything he could well he did
everything he could he didn't do
everything that could have been done by
someone more competent
right but the the tools you have as a
president you could do a lot of things
you can declare emergencies especially
doing covid you could postpone the
election you can create military
conflict that you know any kind of
reason to postpone the election there's
there's a lot of what he tried to do
things and he would have to have done
those things through other people and
they're people who refuse to do those
things the people who said they would
quit they would they would quit publicly
right I mean this is you start again
there are multiple books written about
uh all in the last hours of of this
presidency and the details are shocking
in what he tried to do and tried to get
others to do and it's awful right I mean
it's it's just awful that we were that
close
to something
um
to a true unraveling of our political
process and it's the only time in our
lifetime that anything like this has
happened and
um is deeply embarrassing right for uh
you know on the world stage it's just
like we looked like a Banana Republic
there for a while and
where the lone superpower it's a bit
it's it's not good right and so we
shouldn't like there's no there's no the
I the people who thought well we just
need to shake things up and this is a
great great way to shake things up and
having people you know storm our capital
and smear [__] on the walls that's just
more shaking things up right it's all
just for the lulls
um there's a nihilism and cynicism to
all of that which again in certain
people it's understandable you know
frankly it's not understandable if
you've got a billion dollars and you're
you you know have a compound in Menlo
Park or wherever it's like they're
people who are cheerleading this stuff
who shouldn't be cheerleading this stuff
and who know that they can get on their
Gulf Stream and fly to their compound in
New Zealand if everything goes to [__]
right so there's a cynicism to all of
that that I think we should be deeply
critical of but what I'm trying to
understand is not
and analyze is not the behavior of this
particular human being but the effect it
had in part on the division between
people as to me the degree the meme
of Sam Harris's brain being broken by
Trump represents
you're like the person I would look to
to bridge the division
well I don't think there is
something profitably to be said
to someone who's truly captivated by the
the the personality Cult of trumpism
right like there's nothing that I'm
going to say to
there's no conversation I'm going to
have with Candace Owens say about Trump
that's going to converge on something
reasonable right you don't think so no I
mean I've tried I haven't tried with
Candace I've tried with you know many
people who
are in that particular orbit I mean I've
I've had conversations with people who
won't admit that there's anything wrong
with Trump anything so I'd like to push
for the empathy versus reason because
when you operate in the space of Reason
yes
but I think there's a lot of power
in you showing in you Sam Harris showing
that you're willing to see the good
qualities of trump publicly showing that
I think that's the way to win over okay
but he has so few of them he has fewer
good qualities than any virtually anyone
I can name right but so he he's funny he
I'll grant you that he's funny he's he's
a good Entertainer there's others look
at just policies and actual impacts yeah
I've admitted that no no so like so I've
admitted that many of his policies I
agree with
many many of us probably so uh
probably more often than not at least on
balance I agree so I I agreed with his
policy that you know we should take
China seriously as an adversary right
and
um I think I mean again that you have to
there's a lot of fine print to a lot of
this because the way he talks about
these things and and many of his motives
that are obvious or things that I um
don't support but I'm gonna take
immigration I think there's
it's obvious that we should have control
of our borders right like I don't see
the argument for not having control of
our borders we should let in who we want
to let in and we should keep out who we
want to keep out and we should have the
same immigration policy so
um I don't I didn't necessarily think it
was a priority to build the wall but I
didn't I never criticized the impulse to
build the wall because if you know tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands of
people are coming across that border and
we are not in a position to know who's
coming
that seems untenable to me so
um and I can recognize that many people
in our society
are on balance the victims of
immigration
because and there is a in in many cases
a zero-sum contest between the interests
of actual citizens and the interests of
immigrants right so I think we should
have a we should have control of our
borders we should have a sane and
compassionate immigration policy we
should have we should let in refugees
right so I you know Trump on refugees
was terrible
um but
no like I would say 80 of the policy
concerns people
uh celebrated in him
are concerns that I either share
entirely or certainly sympathize with
right so like that's not
that's not the issue the issue is
a threat to democracy and something well
the issue is largely what you said it
was it's not so much the person it's the
effect on everything he touches right he
just he has this this superpower of
deranging and destabilizing
uh almost everything he touches and
Sully in the and compromising the
Integrity of almost anyone who comes
into his orbit I mean so he looked at
these people who served you know as
Chief of Staff or you know in various
cabinet positions people had real
reputations you know for for probity and
and level-headedness uh you know whether
you share their politics or not I mean
these were real people these were not
you know some of them were goofballs but
um
uh
you know many people who who just got
totally trashed by
proximity to him and then Trashed by him
when they finally parted company with
him
um
yeah I mean there's just people bent
over backwards to accommodate his Norm
violations and it it was it was bad for
them it was bad for our
our system and
but then but none of that discounts the
fact that
we have um
A system that really needs a proper
house cleaning yes there are bad
incentives and
um entrenched interests and yeah I'm not
a fan of the concept of of
the Deep State uh but because it you
know has been so propagandized but yes
there's there's something like that you
know that is uh not um
flexible enough to respond intelligently
to the needs of the moment right so
there's a lot of rethinking of
government and of institutions in
general that I think
we should do
but we need smart well-informed
well-intentioned people to do that job
and the well-intentioned part is
is hugely important right it's Gentlemen
Just give me someone
who
is not the most
selfish person anyone has ever heard
about in their lifetime right and what
we got with Trump was the like the
literally the one most selfish person I
think anyone could name
I mean and you and again you there's so
much known about this man that's the
thing it's like it predates his
presidency we knew this guy 30 years ago
yeah and and this and this is what to
come back to the those inflammatory
comments about Hunter Biden's laptop
the reason why I can say with confidence
that I don't care what was on his his
laptop is that there is and and that
includes any evidence of corruption on
the on the part of his father right now
there's been precious little of that
that's actually emerged so it's like
there is no as far as I can tell there's
not a big story associated with that
laptop as much as people bang on about a
few emails but
even if there were just obvious
corruption right like Joe Biden was at
this meeting and he took you know this
amount of money from this Shady guy
uh for bad reasons right
given how visible the lives of these two
men have been right given how much we
know about Joe Biden and how much we
know about Donald Trump and how they
have lived in public for almost as long
as I've been alive both of them
the the the the scale of corruption
can't possibly balance out between the
two of them right we I if if you show me
that Joe Biden has this secret life or
he's driving a Bugatti and he's living
like Andrew Tate right and he's do he's
doing all these things I didn't know
about okay then I'm gonna start getting
a sense that all right maybe this guy is
way more corrupt than I realize maybe
there is some deal in Ukraine or with
China that is just like this guy is not
who he seems he's not the public servant
he's been pretending to be he's been on
the take for decades and decades and
he's just he's as dirty as can be he's
all mobbed up and it's a nightmare
um and he can't be trusted right that's
possible
if you show me that his life is not at
all what it seems but on the assumption
that I having looked at this guy for
literally decades right and and knowing
that every journalist has looked at him
for decades just how many Affairs does
he have and just how much you know uh
how many drugs is he doing how many
houses does he have where you know what
what what is what are the obvious
conflicts of interest you know you hold
that against what we know about Trump
right and
I mean the Litany of indiscretions you
can put on Trump's side that that
testify to his personal corruption to
testify the fact that he has no ethical
compass
there's simply no comparison right so
that's why I don't care about what's on
the laptop when now if you tell me Trump
is no longer running for president in
2024 and we can put trumpism behind us
and now you're saying listen there's a
lot of stuff on that laptop that makes
Joe Biden look like a total [__] okay
I'm all ears right I mean it was a force
in 2020 it was a force choice between
a sitting president who wouldn't commit
to a peaceful transfer of power
and a guy who's obviously too old
to be president who has a crack addicted
son who who you know who lost his laptop
and I just knew that I was going to take
Biden in spite of whatever Litany of
Horrors was going to come tumbling out
of that laptop and that might involve
sort of so the actual quote is Hunter
Biden literally could have had the
corpses of children in the basement
there's a dark humor to it right which
is I think you speak to I would not have
cared there's nothing it's Hunter Biden
it's not Joe Biden whatever the scopo
Joe Biden's corruption is it is
infinitesimally compared to the
corruption we know Trump was involved in
it's like a firefly to the sun is what
you're speaking to but let me make the
case that you're really focused on the
surface stuff
that it's possible to have corruption
that masquerades in the thing we
mentioned which is civility you commend
you can spend hundreds of billions of
dollars or trillions towards the War uh
in the Middle East for example something
that you've changed your mind on in
terms of the negative impact it has on
the world and that you know the military
industrial complex
it's everybody's very nice everybody's
very civil it's very upfront here's how
we're spending the money yeah sometimes
somehow disappears in different places
but that's the way you know war is
complicated and it's everyone is very
polite there's no uh Coke and strippers
or whatever is on the laptop
um it's very nice and polite in the
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
civilians die uh hate and just an
incredible amount of hate is created
because people lose their family members
all that kind of stuff but there's no
strippers in Coke on a laptop so yeah
but but it's not just superficial it is
when you when someone only wants wealth
and power and fame and so this is that
is their their objective function right
they're like a a robot that is
calibrated just to those variables right
and they don't care about the risks we
run on any other front they don't care
about I mean
environmental risk pandemic risk nuclear
proliferation risk none of it right they
just they're just tracking Fame and
money and and whatever can can
personally uh re down to their
self-interest along those lines and
they're not informed about the other
risks we're running really I mean in
Trump you had a president who was
repeatedly asking his generals why
couldn't we use our nuclear weapons why
can't we have more of them why do I have
fewer nuclear weapons than JFK right as
though that were a sign of of of
anything other than progress right
um
and this is the guy who's got the the
the button right I mean he's got
somebody's following him around with a
bag waiting to take his order to to
launch right
um that is a
it's just it's a it's a risk we should
never run one thing Trump has going for
him I think is that he's he doesn't
drink or do drugs right although there's
you know people allege that he does
speed but
um you know let's take him in his word
he's he's uh not deranging himself with
with Pharmaceuticals at least but
um apart from diet coke uh
but there's nothing wrong just for the
record let me push back on that there's
nothing wrong with that girl yeah that's
a very large amount I occasionally have
some myself there's no medical there's
no scientific evidence that I observed
the negatives of you know all those
studies about aspartame and all that
this um no I don't know if I I hope I
hope you're right
um yeah I mean everything you said about
the military industrial complex is true
right and it's been we've been worrying
about that on both sides of the aisle
for a very long time I mean that's just
that phrase came from from Eisenhower
um
it's uh
I mean so much of
what ails us is a story of bad
incentives right and bad incentives are
so powerful
that they corrupt even good people right
how much more do they corrupt bad people
right like so it's like you want to at
minimum you want reasonably good people
at least non-pathological people in Us
in the system
trying to navigate against the grain of
bad incentives and better still
all of us can get together and try to
diagnose those incentives and change
them right and and and we will really
succeed when we have a system of
incentives where
the the good incentives are so strong
that even bad people are effortlessly
behaving as though they're good people
because they're so successfully
incentivized to behave that way right
that's you know so so it's it's almost
the inversion of our current situation
so yes
and you say I changed my mind about the
War uh
I not quite I mean I I was never a
supporter of the war in Iraq I was
always worried that it was a distraction
from the war in Afghanistan I was a
supporter of the war in Afghanistan and
I will admit in hindsight that looks
like uh
you know at best a highly ambiguous and
painful exercise you know more likely a
Fool's errand right I was like that
would you know it did not turn out well
it's it's
it wasn't for want of trying I I don't
you know I have not done a deep dive on
on all of the failures there and maybe
all of these failures or failures in
principle I mean maybe it's just maybe
that's not the kind of thing that can be
done well by anybody whatever our
intentions
um but yeah the move to Iraq always
seemed questionable to me and um
when we knew the problem the immediate
problem at that moment you know Al Qaeda
uh
was in Afghanistan and you know and then
bounced into Pakistan
um
anyway all you know so yes but my
my sense of the possibility of nation
building my sense of of
um
you know and so insofar as the the the
neocon
um
a spirit of of
you know responsibility and idealism
that you know America was the kind of
nation that should be functioning in
this way as as the world's cop and we've
got we have to get in there and and
untangle some of these knots by force
um uh rather often because
you know if we don't do it over there
we're gonna have to do it over here kind
of thing
um yeah some of that has definitely
changed for me in my thinking
I mean they're obviously cultural
reasons why it failed in Afghanistan and
if you can't change the culture
um it's uh
you're not going to force a change at
gunpoint in the culture or it certainly
seems that that's not going to happen
and it took us you know over 20 years to
apparently to realize that that's one of
the things you realize with the war is
there's not going to be a strong signal
that things are not working you can just
keep pouring money into a thing a
military effort well also there are
signs of it working too you have all the
stories of girls now going to school
right you know the girls are getting
battery acid thrown in their faces by
religious maniacs and then we come in
there and we stop that and now girls are
getting educated and there's a and
that's all good and our intentions are
good there and we're on the right side
of history there good girls should be
going to school you know Malala yosef's
I should have the Nobel Prize and she
shouldn't have been shot in the face by
by the Taliban right
um
we know what the right answers are there
the question is what do you do when
there are enough in this particular case
religious Maniacs who are willing to die
and let their children die in defense of
crazy ideas and moral Norms that belong
in the 7th century
um
and it's a problem we couldn't solve and
we couldn't solve it even though we
spent you know trillions of dollars to
solve it